what do I have going for me like maybe
you love research so making video essay
faceless type of YouTube videos would be
great for you maybe you love
interviewing people and you love to like
buy their books read their books
interview people so a video podcast
would be great for you maybe you love
complex things and you don't need to
make videos simple you need to make like
highly technical videos maybe you like
simple things and so you love to work on
something to make complex things simple
so you could take a topic and make a
Channel with like a beginner advice in
your Niche your topic you gotta find
your angle you got to play to your
strengths don't try to be somebody else
you're going to be you know you were
born an original don't die a copy you
know just like personal development
platitudes just you know like everyone
has quoted that whatever it's still a
good quote though you were born in
original don't die a copy it makes me
think about Mary's nest
you know Mary started YouTube when she
was 60 years old she actually joined our
program called video ranking Academy 60
years old like she couldn't play to her
strength of being a dancing gen Z
hipster you know like she had to play to
the strengths of the fact that she loved
traditional cooking she loved sauerkraut
and sourdough bread and fermenting
things and apple cider vinegar and she
had developed this passion for her whole
life she also isn't crazy like high
energy jump cut YouTube editing she's
not crashing chain trains into giant
sinkholes you know or comparing billion
dollar lots Yachts it's completely her
playing to her own strengths so she
started her YouTube channel making
simple videos she started to invest in
her skills and today she started at 60.
this year she's 65 years old she's gonna
hit a million subscribers Mary's Nest is
getting a gold play button round them
Random House gave Mary a book deal like
what are we talking about and so there's
too many people out there that are like
YouTube is just for this type of person
or that type of person it's just for
people living in this country or that
country and the truth is it's an equal
opportunity platform like you just gotta
play to your strengths you got to be
resourceful you got to figure out your
unique difference position yourself
according to that and downplay your
weaknesses like I suck at a lot of stuff
most things really I just want to play
to the strengths that I have and create
the best content possible for me you
know Sophia armor Russo said true
success lies in knowing your weaknesses
and playing to your strengths
self-awareness is a superpower
not trying to imitate somebody's content
that it's not meant for you two things
number one I've had too much coffee
today number two if you have not seen
our free master class yet you're gonna
love it if you're serious about growing
your YouTube channel just go to
thinkmasterclass.com for a one hour Deep
dive on-demand YouTube strategy class
it's sick and uh I'm gonna go refill my
coffee hope to see you on the class